bonjour bienvenue pour cette édition du
17 octobre 2014 du journal de la
rédaction nous sommes ensemble pour un
peu moins d'une demi-heure voici
quelques-uns des sujets que nous allons
aborder un passeport citoyen délivré à
Bois-d'Arcy la ville propose aux jeunes
de 16 à 25 ans de s'engager et de
devenir solidaire en échange d'une aide
financière pour passer BAFA ou permis de
conduire ils accompagnent les jeux des
enfants depuis 40 ans Playmobil à
l'honneur d'une exposition à Versailles
le château l'Hôtel de Ville reconstitué
et des rencontres avec des passionnés à
découvrir à partir de samedi journée
mondiale du don d'organe lancement d'une
fondation pour récolter des fonds pour
l'université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines ou encore
mobilisation après l'annonce de la mise
en vente du Haras des Brévières par le
Conseil Général des Yvelines comme
chaque fin de semaine l'essentiel de
l'actualité depuis lundi à suivre tout à
l'heure
cet autre information pour débuter grâce
aux 58 000 balles récoltées cette année
au sein des 165 clubs du département
l'opération balle jaune de la Ligue des
Yvelines a permis de créer un sol
sportif adapté de 200 mètres carrés au
sein d'un institut médico-éducatif à
Guyancourt l'immeal fait cet
établissement créé il y a 12 ans
s'occupe de 21 jeunes de 14 à 20 ans
souffrant de troubles de communication
ou de la relation et compte depuis cet
été une championne de France de tennis
adapté elle s'appelle Anaïs elle a 17
ans ce terrain de tennis est le deuxième
sol réalisé dans les Yvelines depuis le
lancement de l'opération balle jaune
c'était en 2008 le président de la ligue
est au micro d'Anthony Rechar présent
ça paye déjà une partie du permis et
puis pour mes études parce que
maintenant les écoles elles sont loin
sur Paris ça fait deux heures de
transport donc le permis ça me sert
vraiment beaucoup pour le futur études
pour le travail je crois que c'était une
bonne initiative ça prouvé que la ville
accompagnait en nous accompagner dans
notre démarche de trouver du travail
d'avoir des compétences des compétences
quoi on avait envie d'avoir un
partenariat gagnant-gagnant avec la
jeunesse en 6e c'était de de donner un
vrai projet une vraie perspective pour
notre jeunesse et essayer de les comment
dire de les éduquer à la citoyenneté en
tout cas de participer à leur éducation
à la citoyenneté
pour recueilli par Patrick Jacques de
Dixmude il faudra faire vite c'est à
partir de samedi et seulement pour
quatre jours que va se tenir à
Versailles une exposition dédiée à
Playmobil des univers des modables qui
ont séduit déjà plusieurs générations
les fameuses petites figurines ont en
effet 40 ans aujourd'hui l'association
la génération playmo en partenariat avec
l'hôtel de ville est en pleine
préparation nous sommes allés ce matin à
leur rencontre avec Patrick
et je suis donc avec Stéphane galinet
bonjour vous êtes l'organisateur pour
génération playmo avec l'hôtel de ville
de cette manifestation de cette
exposition autour des Playmobil qui fête
leur 40 ans ils ont réussi à conquérir
le monde votre passion pour les
Playmobil ça a commencé quand et comment
je pense que ça a commencé en 1974 quand
ils sont sortis j'ai actuellement 46 ans
donc j'avais à l'époque
6 ans donc j'ai eu les premières boîtes
de PLAYMOBIL et puis la passion bon
après on devient adulte on arrête et
puis j'ai eu des enfants et un jour je
leur ai racheté des Playmobil et c'est
comme ça que la passion est revenue donc
j'ai commencé à utiliser les Playmobil
de mes enfants et pour faire des
expositions aujourd'hui combien de
Playmobil vous avez vous les avez tous
non quand on fait des maquettes géantes
là ce qu'on appelle des diorama on est
obligé de se limiter à certains thèmes
sinon on a plus assez de place les
Playmobil c'est 3995 figurines de créer
différentes vos thèmes à vous de
prédilection parce qu'il y a des univers
très différents pour pour Playmobil mais
thème là aujourd'hui c'est ce sont les
Esquimaux les explorateurs moi ce que
j'aime beaucoup sont les hommes de
l'espace les aliens après tout ce qui
est thème des faits le thème de 1900
donc les années à la belle époque et les
chevaliers l'exposition qui va se
dérouler ici à l'hôtel de ville de
Versailles jusqu'à mardi ça va durer
quatre jours il y aura aussi une
reconstitution le montage est en cours
du château de Versailles c'est une pièce
qui existe véritablement le château de
Versailles qui a été créé par les
passionnés bien sûr que non elle
n'existe pas le but et l'objet de cette
exposition c'était de monter ce château
de Versailles ici il avait déjà été
monté ailleurs mais les deux artistes
qui l'ont créé souhaité absolument venir
le faire à Versailles d'où les démarches
de génération playmo la mairie de
Versailles qui nous a entendu et qui a
accepté que les deux artistes puissent
venir le faire ici sont des pièces rares
on imagine qu'il n'y a pas beaucoup qui
ont été créés comme ça ce sont le
château est fait à partir de pièces
rares c'est ce qu'on appelle la maison
1900 sorties dans les années à la fin
des années 80
donc c'est très dur de trouver les
pièces les fenêtres donc ils ont mis 4
ans pour trouver les pièces pour pouvoir
faire le château c'est un projet qui
leur a pris quatre ans
à travailler autour de tout ça et vous
venez de toute la France et même au-delà
ils viennent d'Allemagne
en France on va dire que des expositions
comme celle là il y en a à peu près 15
par an dans toute la France sur la
région parisienne il y en a que deux
donc Versailles c'était le champ de
course d'Enghien il y a 15 jours
donc c'est quand même des choses qui
sont relativement rares donc dire
combien on est c'est un peu compliqué
mais c'est souvent à peu près les mêmes
qui tournent autour de toutes les
expositions des fois nous on va dans le
nord des fois on va du côté de Tours
donc il y a des gens dans le sud il y a
des gens dans le nord de la France et
puis il y a les Parisiens qui sont tous
là aujourd'hui en plus de nos amis
belges et allemands l'exposition pour
découvrir avec des pièces uniques vous
l'avez dit et puis c'est aussi
l'occasion pour les amateurs qui sont
moins chevronnés peut-être de compléter
certaines collections il y aura des
ventes aussi d'organiser ici oui donc il
y aura de la vente de d'anciens
Playmobil des boîtes un peu plus rares
des boîtes un peu plus anciennes pas
forcément rares et pas forcément cher
donc ça permet de compléter des thèmes
qui ne sont plus en vente actuellement
ou avoir des thèmes modernes il y a un
peu de tout des boîtes neuves de
l'occasion on peut trouver du Playmobil
d'occasion donc forcément moins cher ça
ne coûte pas forcément cher j'insiste
là-dessus mais il y en a pour tous les
prix on pourra trouver des Playmobil à 2
euros comme on pourra trouver des boîtes
à 150 euros et là il y en a pour toutes
les bourses merci beaucoup on va vous
laisser continuer à l'installation de
cette exposition qui va se dérouler
jusqu'au 21 octobre ici Hôtel de Ville
de Versailles et on retourne à présent
sur le plateau du journal
et quels sont vos souvenirs de
playmobilier vous amateurs de ses jouets
l’êtes-vous encore c'est notre question
du jour forcément
en France non mais avec mes enfants oui
puisque je les ai emmenés à Playmobil
Fun Park et on a passé des heures à
s'amuser à rigoler dans ce grand parc à
Fresnes
avec ma famille surtout mes cousins les
cousines on a joué souvent quand on
était petit c'était pas ma génération
donc
faire plaisir aux enfants aux petits
enfants vous savez je me rappelle
j'avais plein de trucs chez moi de
Playmobil j'avais plein de petites
maisons plein de petits trucs
de garçons
quand on joue avec mes potes et tout
c'était sympa quoi puis les
constructions de ça il y a des trucs que
les parents les acheter les maquettes
tout ça les voitures qu'on pouvait après
conduire avec des piles tout ça il y a
plein de trucs qui sont sympas à faire
avec des Playmobil et l'exposition c'est
donc à versa jusqu'au 21 octobre nous en
reparlerons de notre prochaine édition
de lundi bien sûr santé à présent comme
chaque année en France plus de 50000
femmes développent un cancer du sein un
dépistage précoce permet de guérir cette
maladie afin d'inciter les femmes à se
faire dépister l'association octobre
rose organise aujourd'hui une journée de
sensibilisation à Trappes aujourd'hui
autour de différentes animations
le dispositif dépistage organisé du
cancer du sein s'est à partir de 50 ans
tous les deux ans et jusqu'à 74 ans
avant 50 ans on recommande aux femmes
donc de se suivre régulièrement on sait
qu'un cancer détecté tôt sera guéri dans
9 cas sur 10 autour de nous ce matin en
fait il y a une compagnie Théâtre donc
la compagnie Isabelle startier sous des
parapluies roses des comédiennes
racontent des histoires sur un ton
humoristique mais sur le dépistage du
cancer du sein pour inviter les femmes à
faire leur mammographie elle est très
intéressante et puis la dame comment
très très bien c'est très important mais
malheureusement je trouve que ça démarre
même trop tard je trouve qu'on devrait
commencer à partir de 40 ans pour la
gratuité je parle
l'association sera également présente ce
soir vendredi pour la projection d'un
film à 20h30 au grenier à selle attrape
pour une projection qui sera suivie d'un
débat également
c'est aujourd'hui le 17 octobre Journée
mondiale du don d'organes et le constat
et malheureusement toujours le même il
est difficile d'augmenter le nombre de
donateurs d'années en année comme nous
l'a expliqué la coordinatrice
hospitalière des prélèvements du centre
hospitalier de Versailles elle était
l'invité du journal cette semaine
le taux de refus en France ne fait
qu'augmenter en Île-de-France il est à
37,4 c'est à dire qu'une personne
chauffe 3 une famille sur trois refuse
dans l'organisme de son proche on fait
beaucoup de campagne d'informations on
fait beaucoup de choses mais
malheureusement c'est un évolue pas
beaucoup et c'est très dommage parce que
la liste d'attente elle continue
d'augmenter d'année en année et
malheureusement tous les ans des
personnes vont décéder ou être tirés de
liste d'attentes parce que effectivement
il n'y a pas suffisamment de d'organes
disponibles et où les personnes décèdent
ou alors leur état est tellement grave
qu'elles sont retirées de la liste
d'attente parce qu'elles ne peuvent plus
être greffer faute d'avoir parce
qu'elles ont attendu trop longtemps sans
septembre le pape François qui a appelé
à développer le don d'organes afin de
mettre fin au trafic j'imagine que vous
étiez plutôt satisfaite sans rentrer
dans les considérations de religion même
si ça peut être un frein au don
également d'entendre le pape appeler au
développement du don c'est formidable il
faut savoir que sur les grandes
religions monothéistes qu'on trouve en
France il
après c'est souvent un argument qui nous
est avancé par méconnaissance des choses
quel que soit les religions il n'y a pas
de de restriction là-dessus et c'est
vrai que par méconnaissance quelquefois
les gens disent non malheureusement ne
m'autorise pas ça m'est déjà arrivé de
faire intervenir soit le mode rite
Versailles soit un imam à l'hôpital
Cochin puisqu'on travaille aussi en
réseau qui a effectivement vu les
proches en dehors de notre présence pour
pas pour rester très neutre et qui a
effectivement après autoriser les
proches rassurer les proches en disant
non non la religion de l'interdit pas
formellement vous pouvez accepter le
prélèvement d'organes et donc là
effectivement la décision du pape c'est
formidable j'espère qu'elle sera
entendue parce que il faut que à ce
niveau là que ça bouge beaucoup
l'actualité santé cette semaine c'était
aussi le vaccin contre la grippe
disponible en pharmacie une maladie qui
peut entraîner des complications graves
et qui provoquent chaque année des décès
une campagne de vaccination nationale a
débuté le 13 octobre la tension est
portée évidemment sur les personnes les
plus fragiles 10 millions de Français
vont pouvoir en bénéficier gratuitement
les 65 ans et plus se souffrant de
certaines affections de longue durée
l'entourage familiale des nourrissons de
moins de 6 mois présentant des facteurs
de risque grave également
c'est important pour pas avoir la grippe
parce que la grippe et ça doit être le
virus le plus mortel du monde en
nombre de personnes qui sont tuées dans
le monde tous les ans ils revient tous
les ans tous les ans il y a un nouveau
vaccin parce que tous les ans le vaccin
change en fait donc on connaît le vaccin
parce que de l'autre côté du monde en
fait il est déjà acquis et il revient
avec une souche donc on prépare les
vaccins avant la vaccination parce qu'on
sait la souche vaccinale qui sera
efficace entre 2014 et 2015 l'année
prochaine comme l'année d'avant c'est un
autre vaccin
toujours cette semaine l'équinoxe a fêté
c'est 5 ans l'équinoxe c'est cette
structure qui accueille et accompagne
des personnes en difficulté un centre
d'hébergement de réinsertion sociale à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux sans 10 places
pour des femmes seules en rupture
d'hébergement et pour des individuels ou
des familles en situation très précaires
le contexte économique actuel rend
difficile ces missions nous en avons
parlé sur ce plateau lundi avec la
directrice de l'établissement en
écoutant l'extrait de cet entretien nous
sommes 17 CHRS dans les Yvelines
effectivement avec je crois 780 places
d'accueil entre les places d'urgence de
stabilisation et d'insertion et bien
évidemment vous connaissez ma réponse
bien non les besoins sont bien
supérieurs aux possibilités d'accueil un
profil particulier peut être qui revient
ces dernières années ce sont les
personnes en situation irrégulière
personne étrangères
effectivement sur l'urgence les deux
premières années de fonctionnement nous
avions moins de situations irrégulières
les trois dernières années cette ce
prorata on va dire a augmenté mais du
fait je pense des orientations puisque
le principe de l'accueil inconditionnel
s'applique la conséquence bien sûr et
moins de possibilités de sortie et de
réorientation pour ses publics là les
universités qui peinent à boucler leur
budget certaines affiches des déficits
si l'université de Versailles 50 ans on
Yvelines a réduit le sien de 5,2
millions à 900 000 euros les dotations
de l'État deviennent toujours moins
importantes et obligent les
établissements à trouver des solutions
alternatives l'université de Versailles
50 ans toujours elle lance une fondation
qui permettra notamment dans un premier
temps de collecter de l'argent pour
financer des ouvrages de la bibliothèque
universitaire nous avons proposé un
débat sur cette antenne mardi dernier
entre enseignants et étudiants dans le
cadre du 7 8 sociétés présentés par
Catherine zelato l'intégralité est à
revoir sur notre site internet voici
néanmoins quelques extraits
pourquoi il y a besoin de lancer un
appel aux dons pour financer des livres
ça veut dire que les livres sont pas
suffisamment financés il y a pas assez
d'argent principe c'est l'État qui doit
financer les ouvrages non alors le
budget l'université c'est un budget
global avec des choses qui sont qui sont
ventilées c'est surtout que pour la
Fondation chercher en fait un sujet qui
soit d'abord centré c'est le démarrage
de la Fondation donc c'est
particulièrement important pour nous et
on cherchait un sujet qui soit centré
sur les étudiants qui soient du
fondamental du savoir
ouvert sur le territoire et qui mettent
sur la table la question
l'investissement de long terme et qui
s'adresse à toutes les facultés toutes
les disciplines et le meilleur sujet que
l'on a trouvé pour ça c'est la
bibliothèque j'ai effectivement donné
pour cette fondation parce que je suis
attaché à mon université et je pense que
chacun peut être attaché à son
université et participer à la vie de son
université de façon économique comme
politique mais avant toute chose il
faudra dire quand même que l'université
de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines comme
toutes les universités publiques de
France ne se sont pas en fait ce sont
pas construites sur des dons c'est
l'état providence qui a mis en place ces
universités et qui les finances et je
pense que la Fondation n'est pas un
outil de remplacement de du financement
de l'université nous continuons à faire
le tour de l'actualité depuis le début
de la semaine dans cette édition du
vendredi du journal et cet alliance
inattendu entre trois anciennes
ministres de gauche avec Catherine taska
du centre avec Chantal Jouanno et de
droite avec Christine Boutin trois
femmes qui s'associent pour défendre le
haras national des brevières le domaine
équestre est en vente vous le savez le
Conseil Général son propriétaire
souhaite s'en séparer une décision qui
ne fait donc pas l'unanimité d'autres
responsables politiques ce sont aussi
fait entendre Yolaine Torres
l'avenir du Haras national des
Bréviaires toujours en suspens depuis
que le Conseil général le propriétaire
des lieux a annoncé sa volonté de le
vendre les réactions sont vives lors de
la séance plénière de l'Assemblée
départementale vendredi dernier les
choses ont toutefois évolué on ne parle
plus de vente mais de faire de faire un
appel à projet ça veut dire que on va
présenter ce qui est notre propre projet
à savoir le parc régional de la filière
cheval
ce projet prévoit de regrouper au
bréviaires le pôle technique régional
pour l'équitation avec un pôle de
formation dédié aux métiers du cheval un
pôle dédié à l'élevage et au commerce
des chevaux ainsi qu'une unité de
méthanisation un projet soutenu par les
acteurs de la région c'est un projet qui
est intéressant pour le suivi parce que
le cheval est très présent dans cette
partie du territoire yvelinois et c'est
un projet qui a sa cohérence et qui va
permettre de dynamiser l'économie locale
du cheval je puis vous dire que nous
sommes vigilants et que de toute façon
d'une façon ou d'une autre ce projet
verra le jour j'en suis absolument
convaincu la question qui se pose
aujourd'hui c'est de savoir si le
département des Yvelines sera partenaire
ou non de ce projet c'est pas
obligatoirement une participation
financière pour moi nous sommes déjà
propriétaire du territoire mais nous
devons être une partie prenante puisque
sera des conséquences des retombées
économiques culturelles sociales sur
notre département
Pierre Bédier le président du conseil
général avait annoncé qu'il n'était pas
exclu que le département reste
propriétaire des lieux mais que dans Sky
le prendrait plus en charge l'entretien
la décision quant à ce projet devrait
être rendue vers la fin du mois de
janvier
transport et la présentation cette
semaine du pôle multimodal de Versailles
c'est sur le site de la gare Versailles
chantier que l'événement s'est déroulé
en présence notamment du président
socialiste de la région Jean-Paul Huchon
l'Île-de-France finançant le chantier
presque pour moitié à hauteur de 28
millions d'euros dans le détail cette
garde va connaître un important en
chantier d'aménagement de rénovation sur
deux ans l'accent sera mis sur les
liaisons avec les différents modes de
transport dont le bus
le Versailles à Trappes transport
urbanisme toujours avec le dossier de
l'enfouissement de la nationale 10 qui
avance à grand pas à l'enquête publique
pourrait avoir lieu avant la fin de
l'année au plus tard tout début 2015 les
derniers détails c'est avec Catherine
zulator
un dossier à l'arrêt celui de
prolongement de l'autoroute A12 et un
autre qui suit bien son cours celui de
la couverture de la nationale 10 à
Trappes il est bel et bien acté et les
travaux pourraient même démarrer en 2016
c'est ce que confirmé le maire de la
commune Guy Malandain les études
techniques sont en cours d'études de sol
ont été faites les problèmes de réseau
et tout ça tout ça est fait maintenant
on va passer à l'enquête publique et le
calendrier de l'État qui est qui est
maître d'ouvrage et et est en début de
travaux deuxième semestre 2016
l'enquête publique pourrait se dérouler
à la fin de cette année ou en début
d'année 2015 c'est le premier projet
retenu dans les accords et ta région
dans les aménagements routiers
d'Île-de-France il s'agit de requalifier
la nationalité sans boulevard urbain et
de l'enfouir sur 300 m de créer
également deux ronds-points à l'entrée
de la ville au niveau du Bailly en bleu
et l'autre en sortie près de la station
BP un plateau urbain sera réalisé devant
la mairie pour relier les quartiers
entre eux chaque jour 70 000 véhicules
empreintes cette nationale les premiers
plans d'enfouissement de la RN 10 date
de 1998
c'est la fin du journal on se retrouve
lundi pour une nouvelle semaine
d'information locale excellente soirée
excellent weekend sur notre antenne